we're not into relationship advice first
one is from amber B what's up girl he
has a little girl who's five who I've
yet to meet because she lives in a
different state sure she's lying and one
night I wake up to him in the middle of
the night telling me oh by the way baby
momma's decided to move to Georgia which
is where we're at um with my kid but
don't worry everything's gonna be fine
hmm
there's nothing to worry about I don't
want anything juicer okay there's been
some red flags I really feel in my gut
that there's more to the situation than
I know
and basically I'm wanting advice for my
two favorite people on whether I should
trust my gut or Mother's him coming in
trust him and believe him and see where
it goes
appreciate it guys sorry about the dog
anyway [ __ ] ah dog oh god damn chance
you don't fall bro even and see where it
goes
appreciate it guys sorry about the dog
anyway the Wow I love you I want to say
that back before we keep moving forward
you seem like a ceiling like someone
who's been doing good stuff and he's
like a nice person seem like a really
good person yeah now you're in
relationship but you just threw dick
shade towards my boy so how serious is a
relationship if you're trying to go
after the Rat King look you might get
cheesy you know that's all I'm saying
you might get a little wet you're so
[ __ ] with the rat oh you might get
some wet cheese you might get some Brie
yeah here's what I'm saying is this what
are you saying Brendon I'm saying that
if it's the love of your life
hey he's not a terrible person cuz baby
mom was moving back to Georgia and she
wants the kid to be closer with the dad
that's not a red flag but she doesn't
more to it you know she just gets these
vibes or something else going on like
she's never met the kid it sounded the
guy is married or still putting it back
together you know a lot of guys I'll
tell you this young lady's and I hate to
tell you this a lot of guys are still
married you don't want to hear that but
they are so you know they are dude and
you're right man but with the one thing
if it's their soul mate and they're that
close just because the baby mom was
moving back because she wants the kid
have relationship with the dad doesn't
mean he's a bad dude right it doesn't
mean the guy was a bad guy that's life
if he's hiding more [ __ ] and catch him
line and if he's a bonafide liar then
yeah move on and I can also slide in
your DM that gives you feel phone number
well why I could just do that why are
you getting into redeems she's upstairs
has he already made on her play ha ha ha
on that filter for me bro we've gone
over this I'm your filter you are yeah I
can't just let anyone get to the Rat
King you got to go through this baby
buzz buzz gotta get to the honey forget
to the rap don't there bro I'm like the
security guard for a van Halen
you want to [ __ ] the band you gonna
start with me you got to start in the
van get that honey turn that van full of
honey buzz buzz girl we'll see if you
get enough for the rat dude well you got
a honey we got cheese or like a chart
shooter replay rush so let me say this
young lady I think you gotta trust your
instincts it sounds like your instincts
are telling you there's some red flags
here you said red flags I need more info
though before I throw this dude down the
gutter do you I don't think you do I've
been this dude and he's a [ __ ] bag kid
huh you have more kids that I know but
I'm pretending I've had kids somewhere
they're coming back to have Georgia okay
you know everybody's got that kid travel
on the Underground Railroad or whatever
excuse you use you know so I would say
this that I think you got to take some
time for yourself do some things for
yourself if this guy's a soul mate then
it's gonna work out but I would start to
I would start to have a little bit more
time for yourself you know so don't be
at his beck and call
don't be at it nah put them up put a
little distance put them on that Fiji
Island you know I'm saying yeah so
you've been Dame for a year and there's
red flags soul mate let's chill a little
bit
soul plane maybe see if you guys can get
through soul playing together without
[ __ ] yeah watch soul plan and see if you
can avoid his cockatiel yeah cuz some
movies you just supposed to watch you
know supposed to [ __ ] seven minutes into
it and then just be sitting there eleven
minutes into it with [ __ ] not knowing
what's going on you know the real trick
see if you can watch Soul plane and not
talk for the entire movie yeah it gets
through that you got to keep her yeah I
think you'd put them on that soul plane
test good luck girl
[Music]